There's a hurricane comin'
We gotta go
Agent Corbyn reporting in
Six hundred million
Vault loaded?
It's all here with about three hundred million of its cousins
It's your responsibility
I'm alright at babysitting old money
We're on lock down due to the storm
Come on man
Oh boy
Turn around now
Do it
This is not good
No witnesses
What the hell was that  about?
The treasury's being robbed
Where is she?
They need me. I'm the only one with the code
We gotta go get my brothe r
I need your help
Let's go save the world
What in the hell?
Well, I am a citizen of Alabama
Yeah!
We're about to be crushed by the biggest storm of the century
Look out!
I knew today was gonna be
Let's load up
Go!
This is gonna be harsh!
What?
Here comes the harsh part
Here goes nothin'
You better hope not
Let's get the money
That thing wants to swallow us whole
Hell of a day, ain't it?
Hell of a day!